on ouvre une page économie à présent 300
millions d'euros pour la filière
aéronautique
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le gouvernement
dans son plan de relance un fonds de
soutien pour moderniser le secteur
parmi ces 300 millions 2,5 millions pour
deux entreprises de touraine mecachrome
irait aux rêves des subventions
conditionné à des investissements de
leur part le but préparer le futur
au lendemain de la crise économique avec
ce que l'on appelle l'industrie 4.0
explications samuel colin réaux rêve et
mecachrome 10 millions d'euros
d'investissement à eux deux dont trois
de subventions
objectif final accélérer le passage à
l'usiné 4.0 autrement dit optimisé par
le numérique
si on veut pérenniser des emplois en
europe c'est par cette mise à niveau de
notre industrie qu'il faut que l'homme
que l'on opère à cette transformation
c'est une aide précieuse extrêmement
ciblées qui va nous permettre de passer
un cap passé le cap de la digitalisation
car ces millions d'euros sont aussi
destinés aux projets de recherche et
développement du groupe 2020 est une
année noire pour le secteur aéronautique
mecachrome voit son chiffre d'affaires
baisser de 40%
l'entreprise annonce un plan social et
un quart des emplois supprimés à amboise
il n'est donc pas question de
recrutement dans l'immédiat pour le
député de la circonscription
les subventions accordées ont un effet
de levier et sont à voir dans un temps
plus long c'est vraiment un coup de
pause qui permet à ces entreprises de
s'engager dans un investissement lié à
la modernisation ou à l'innovation de
leur appareil de production oui c'est
pour le coup d'après et il faut ne pas
croire que cette crise va durer
indéfiniment des subventions et des
investissements pour pérenniser
l'activité
ces deux groupes font également
travailler d'autres plus petites
entreprises
mille cinq cents personnes travaillent
dans le secteur aéronautique
en indre et loire